we are learning more about the two
toddlers killed in a suspected DUI crash
in North Las Vegas happened Sunday night
good evening to you thanks for joining
us at five I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise
Valdez the toddlers were little girls
we're also learning more about what
police believe caused that gruesome
crash Ryan mathie joins us live near
Lone Mountain in Clayton and Ryan
neighbors say they're all too familiar
with traffic trouble there right
yeah unfortunately Denise and Brian
they're very aware of it before we get
into that though let's start with the
coroner's office they have since
identified those two toddlers as
three-year-old Taylor Wilmer and
two-year-old Rose Wilmer and you can see
just over my shoulder here this Memorial
it's formed yesterday several people
have been coming in since then it's a
memorial along this road it's the
accessible neighborhoods here and you
can see all these homes the people
living inside them however they say
Sunday's crash it joins a growing list
of incidents here with seemingly no
solution in sight
[Music]
a site Davis Mallory says he's seen
before my wife she was in the bedroom
right there at that time so if they
would have went through that wall he was
going to go right into the bedroom where
she was at this palm tree is what he
says prevented four to five cars from
slamming into his backyard they go down
that street like super fast the
sprinklers come on at night time so when
the sprinklers come on they the water
drips down on that side of the road like
right by my back wall right there where
that tree is at and they slide every
single time right into that tree
a blind spot on Scott Robinson Boulevard
with no speed bumps or stop signs where
a single vehicle took the lives of two
little girls just heard it loud it
sounded like a gunshot ping Andrew
Maldonado who lives on one of the
corners says a car rammed into his
family's backyard years ago the drivers
allegedly emerging with alcohol bottles
in their hands definitely gave us
anxiety just let alone even being in our
backyard oh when's the next person going
to come through and smash their backyard
North Las Vegas Police confirmed
Sunday's crash was the fourth vehicle
collision here this year and was even
higher over the past two years also this
year the department received a hundred
thousand State dollars to address
impaired driving and 176 000 to reduce
vehicle fatalities but neighbors still
fearing the next crash could be in their
backyard this backyard the traded like a
NASCAR rally you know it's like it's
like there's no speed limit here
now neighbors say they've asked for
speed control measures here for years a
city representative tells me that speed
bumps they're not an option it's because
of how the road is designated and how it
would impede emergency vehicle access
but that representative does add that
the new enforcement efforts with those
new Grant dollars could be directed
specifically here to this road reporting
live from Lone Mountain and Clayton Ryan
Matthey a news now
so altogether the city and police
received more than four hundred thousand
dollars in Grants to respond to reckless
driving and that includes DOI
checkpoints and enhanced enforcement of
speeding laws we can also tell you
tonight that the two adult passengers of
Sunday's crash still remain in the
hospital and have not been identified